the second concerns wayne cousins who  pleaded guilty to kidnap and rape of  sarah everard  and later he pleaded guilty to her  murder  on the 30th of september 2021 he was  sentenced to imprisonment for life for  the murder with a whole life order  no separate penalty was imposed for the  offences of kidnapping and rape  cousin seeks leave to appeal  against sentence  in his case we grant leave to appeal  against sentence but dismiss the appeal  although the circumstances of his case  do not fall within the terms of the  statutory provision which provides that  a whole life order should be the normal  starting point  the individual facts are such that the  judge was entitled exceptionally to  impose a whole life order